um is this like does mama get to have a
little night out tonight yes
yes it was it was nice
although evie as i was leaving she said
mommy you look like a disney princess
you're rapunzel marine so you know in my
house that is a huge compliment yeah
right thank you so much
there it is she goes but you have
extensions in oh my gosh like she knows
she goes you have extensions in mom
i said
wait a minute she knows that's kind of
she knows
so she says mom looks like a princess
that has to feel pretty cool that mama
looks like a princess and mama is going
to an event about the power of women how
do you instill that in her as a mother
and raising an incredible daughter oh
thank you um i i think a lot of it has
to do with living for your truest
highest best self and going after your
dreams and believing in yourself and at
the same time
putting your family first and she sees
that i have my priorities in the right
place but she also sees that i love what
i do and i'm able to
go after that and and work hard and fail
and succeed and all of that and i think
that there's that's good for little
girls to see
yeah the failures and the successes that
such yes yes and and to be open about
that you know and talk to her about that
soon i try how powerful is she with
little brother how's she doing as a big
sister she's amazing she's a really good
big sister i am every day impressed by
her like she's helpful
she's funny she plays with him he
adores her actually she's basically you
know she's like in charge tonight so she
was like this is what we do we put the
books then we go to bath and we go to
bed so she's like a little mama it's so
sweet
you've got a future built-in babysitter
there that's helpful i know it's nice
the age difference is nice it helps so
you got to get dressed up tonight but
you know i got to ask you about i read
that you're like we don't know what to
do with this wedding planning thing
where are you at how are you figuring it
out we are literally still just talking
about it it's been you know we got we
got engaged
had calum and then
covid quarantine happened so you know
obviously our priorities were more on
keeping ourselves safe and our family
and i think when we're able to have a
safe gathering and you know life kind of
relaxes a bit we can focus on that do
you want to do it big small is it i i
don't know if we know if it's gonna be
big or small but we know we want it to
be intimate and and
you know the people we love the most and
not a a huge affair something that's
really meaningful but it sounds like you
want to be able to relax and not stress
yes yes yeah there's no rush when you've
had the baby i mean that's the
commitment right i mean that's true
one thing i've always loved though i've
interviewed steve and i've interviewed
you and it seems like he is the type of
guy who really lifts you up as a woman
oh he does that's really sweet that you
picked that up yeah he really is in
support of powerful women in all ways
and he really supports me and believes
in me and actually makes me feel
wonderful about all the different
aspects of myself and my work and life
and as a mom and yeah he's so so
supportive it's great you know what
that's what we should be telling our
daughters look for that you know that's
what so that's the number one thing it's
wonderful right so what brought you out
here tonight are there any of these
other powerful women you're especially
excited to meet i am excited to see
everybody here truly everybody chanting
is amazing i'm also very very excited
about katie being here so yeah all
everyone being honored is is a room of
powerful women so i'm
ecstatic to be here and what's next for
you work wise i well right now i'm on
the rookie so that'll be coming out um
and i have a show called come dance with
me which is a really fun
dance
reality it's light up when you get to
dance it's like thank you yeah
i am very very excited about this show i
think it's gonna be um it's family
it's a shiny floor show it's great
performances it has a lot of heart so
that'll be next year so look at that on
cbs yeah
thank you should we treat this as a
possible glimpse of the wedding look
like daughter gosh i mean my goodness
evie approved so that's all that matters
[Music]